being honest is a very solitary
existence you create most of them create
works in by themselves in this studio in
an environment so I think for them to
think that they represent a cultural
nation or work collectively I think is a
difficult concept for a lot of them I
think that they create works that might
offer a very important commentary on
certain things but I don't know that
they would ever feel like they could be
involved in the kind of preservation of
a local culture I think of their works
might be interpreted in that way but I
don't know that any of them would ever
feel that that was their role within
society